[Music]
all right check this out remember
dashing the psychic vampire
bro how could i ever got lit
okay
now
you have to get used to the to the wheel
you're still doing this frames per
minute yeah yeah but honestly
this becomes art i promise
i wouldn't steer you wrong
so it doesn't matter what they're saying
now because it builds up and you will
hear what they're saying he's arguing
with his boyfriend as we know randy
right frozen randy
randy i think yeah the boyfriend
ricky ricky the boyfriend ricky so
they're having a talk they're fighting
now
ricky thinks that dashton cheated on him
just so you know where where this is
starting and
here we go put you out for that and no
one has so get over yourself yeah that
guy with the blonde hair hat there we go
the guy with the blonde hair has
[ __ ]
you stayed there
away from
oh wow he punched him oh wow for real
that's up right in his [ __ ] face dude
[ __ ] shot look above his eye cut he
got color
i can't see am i
i'll be hospital
that's what you call hard way
yeah i got it the hard way
this is the last time i can see on my
eye i don't know what i'm gonna do
now merce you might be wondering
how did we get here
what what happened
well i have the answer
and not to my face i'm gonna do exactly
what i told you
okay i'm sorry nothing's wrong okay
get out please don't
okay be nice now remember what i said
you're going to remember what i said
okay i mean you are going to talk your
[ __ ] in my face so remember that go park
your car we're going to go yeah we're
going to mark i love that they're all
like violent crazy meth heads but they
all sound like uh
uh uh what's his name uh the the father
from the chrisley show
oh yeah yeah oh god uh something what
what's his name frozen what chrisley
oh it's been a while jesus cause i know
right after i hit you they're gonna call
the police
now this is before he got punched do
exactly what i told y'all happened to
you okay i'm sorry nothing's wrong okay
i mean you're gonna get a microphone
okay thank you
now i'm gonna punch you like i said no
one's not in the car i'm gonna break
your jaw no don't do that i'm gonna show
you how powerful i am right after you
got done
i know you do not cause a scene over
here be nice and quiet
this is really severe do not do that
this is where you got to be nice to me
and we're going to go walk get a machine
you know real one free one i'm going to
give you a free one
i'll see you all day i promise i promise
right after you [ __ ] somebody i love you
and right after you [ __ ] somebody so
he's pissed because he thinks he that he
cheated i didn't do nothing why did you
make me walk because there's sean a lot
of y'all probably that's too scary i
love you i'm not allowed to be on your
property but i've got to talk to canada
if you don't believe me but i'm not
going to let you record
okay we're fine let's go ahead
i don't think they're on drugs though
and there's the little aftermath of the
uh punching
that's not great
you know i'd say that they probably are
not in they're in a pretty toxic
relationship
oh yeah no they are so they i think they
might need a break so then he calls him
i get my eyesight away and now you want
to be away from me
my mom said she would call them you for
assaults
is that what you want
this one's on heroin the other one's on
meth is my take
yeah maybe you don't do different drugs
opposites attractive you're gonna be no
but if you're gonna be in a relationship
you guys gotta be on the same dope
that's actually a very good point
oh okay hold on he'll not help you can't
be you can't be all messed up ready to
go stealing copper wire and [ __ ] from
like a new construction house at three
in the morning but i'm all [ __ ]
slammed on fence and i can't even get up
like that you're never gonna get along
you're never gonna you know they're
gonna think you don't have enough uh uh
uh drive and ambition and you're gonna
be like well yeah but you stress me out
you're always nagging me wanting to go
steal copper wiring don't touch it
anymore
it's okay my mom did that
it don't work there it goes watch this
it's crazy
i love you though don't do this meet me
down there at marquis
huh
huh don't worry
well listen to me go down the marks i'll
stay away from here stay away from this
unit you're take cautious
i've indian heritage in my hair i have
indian heritage that's why i'm i'm an
indian
she isn't he hasn't touched my car with
that or anything indian harry don't
touch my car without don't talk that's
right because that's what they that's
what native americans call themselves
like go on my car get off my car
go over there
it's like oh my god it really is like a
zombie movie told you look at him
just get off of it i'm looking to look
at them
i would never do something so rude to
anybody
that's my car tweaking oh dude
he is tweaking really hard come on a
little bit
look at his mouth go somewhere before
you make everyone feel threatened
huh
it's broken [ __ ] i told you my
freaking thing broke oh it's broken by
the way root or bigger in the chat cops
and dope don't mix do they mr leahy
yeah native american choker necklace
that's why i got this choker from
claire's cause i'm naked because i'm
indian
please i wanna park my car and he drops
it like it's hot drop it like it's hot
drop it like a top now he starts working
see
drop it like it's hot i need to go to
the store oh wait no come with me to
mcdonald's
move out of the road
get out of here
this this looks like
like somebody on the news or somebody or
like they made a documentary
and they were too cheap to pay for the
footage
right so they were like well we'll just
use the audio and we'll do like
freeze frames from the video so we don't
have to pay them for the full video this
just feels like somebody didn't want to
license it it's like all right we'll
just show or it's one of those things
where they're like what we're about to
show you is graphic we'll only be
showing you and they only show you like
freeze frames yeah the audio
so this is after he got punched he can't
even drive
i can't even drive him to me
i mean you can still drive my eye
doesn't go back go back to what you got
punched it's going to swell up it
happens money can't fix this money can't
fix that i don't know what's going to
fix this
i gotta drive all this crying blood
i think i could see better with him okay
i'm matching frappuccino
mom i can't see
i don't know but this is what it looks
like
so then he go check this out
he got punched now
let's say you got punched
right someone jumped you got punched can
i well can i just
i don't mean to correct you yeah that
would never happen no i didn't it didn't
but but i'm not talking about that i
would end their life
with my bare hands
[Music]
we're going to find out because i'm
going to punch you so we're going to
find out
but let's say you get punched right
you get jumped and you get punched
what's the first thing you do
you're bleeding from the eye like him
what do you do first thing you do well i
will probably try to get out of there
first of course of course then
and then probably go get some ice of
course ice pack get uh some some gauze
maybe a little bacteria no no no no what
you do is you go to mcdonald's
while bleeding in the eye he hasn't even
wiped it off yet you're right you got it
okay
yeah i'd probably hit the cvs first
watch this
what do you think he's gonna ask the
drive-thru guy what is the thing he
always asks people
with a bleeding eye what's your sign yep
yep
i knew it it's [ __ ] up
be so funny if that's the guy like
that's the guy's last straw this is what
makes him quit
there's a guy is some gay meth tweaker
pulling up in a claire's [ __ ] choker
with a bloody eye and going what's your
astrological sign and the guy goes
i'm done i'm done i'm not doing this
anymore i quit
all right check this out
what is your astrology sign
okay what's your astrology science art i
don't know what that is well my thing
for you huh what my three right
i don't know what that is you like your
astrology sign like i was with everybody
i'm a pisces aquarius i guess
thank you for so kindly cool
all right you too i'm just trying to get
myself together second ride
and for him to get himself together he
needs to know what this uh employee from
mcdonald's uh his sign is
capricorn by the way
is there anything
more useless than astrology like like
yes yes
liberal arts degree have you found that
that's like a deal breaker with women
yeah that's a deal breaker with people
in general like
i i'm not i can't i don't even entertain
it i don't care
i can't get into it i refuse to get into
it it's the dumbest thing in the world
to me is there anything worse than you
me like a cute chick you know and you're
hitting it off and then she's like i
should do like your reading and you're
like
you guys are being real virgos right now
this was good
that's exactly what a capricorn would
say
yeah spoken like a true church mouse
[Laughter]
i just can't focus correctly with both
eyes once yes because you got punched in
one of them that's gonna happen for a
little bit
by the way 412 says the ancients i think
used it to tell seasons coming and going
yeah and it worked back then but now we
have like google to tell us stuff when
to set our clocks and now it's it's it's
whether or not a girl's going to date
somebody depending on what month they
were born in
yeah
for the other ones
seem different
like i think i can see i think i can see
i think i can
function well yeah you got punched in
the eye you're not blind
like it's you know to blind somebody
requires and by the way
i think people vastly underestimate just
how tough the eyeball is it's very tough
because you can scr like we've all had
an eyeball injury i'm sure in our
lifetimes uh you can cut it you can re
it can really take a good amount of like
pressure
before it's like you know destroyed or
anything like
eyes can take a pretty good little
beating there so a little people are
like oh my god i want to go blind it's
like it might [ __ ] your eyesight up
permanently a little bit but
the eyes are pretty goddamn resilient
little parts of the body
well speaking of eye
then he does this
[Music]
oh my god look at his nails
dude jerry cantrell is looking rough
is that a coke nail
there's a different finger
so anyway like that's the end of that
well i mean any nail is a coke now if
you're not
if you got the will to make it work if
you're not a [ __ ] right